aujourd'hui on a organisé une journée
qui s'appelait paris saclay à l'heure de
l'économie collaborative l'innovation
sociale l'idée l'objectif c'est de
questionner ce territoire très
estampillé innovations scientifiques
innovations technologies sur sa capacité
à innover autrement qui existe des
porteurs de projets des associations qui
travaillent sur des thématiques beaucoup
plus social qui touche à l'environnement
ou à l'économie collaborative et qui
peuvent être également innovantes et
donc c'est vraiment cette question là
qu'on a voulu poser aujourd'hui à toute
l'assemblée des participants on a eu
près de dix porteurs de projets du
territoire de paris saclay qui sont
venus nous développer leur objectif est
un peu parler de ce qui leur manquait en
termes d'outils en termes de financement
aujourd'hui il ia smart auto stop smart
auto stop
c'est la première application qui va
mettre en relation des piétons qui
prennent les transports en commun ou qui
ont des difficultés pour se déplacer
avec les automobilistes qui leur passent
devant et donc ça vient compléter
l'offre de transport existantes
le stop en fait pour des raisons de
sécurité a arrêté son développement et
grâce aux applications smartphones et
notamment aux smartphones
aujourd'hui on est capable de non
seulement de géolocaliser les gens dans
la rue donc de les mettre en relation au
temps elle mais on est surtout aussi
capables d'utiliser notation de la
communauté pour donner une sécurité dans
le service qui est essentiel au
développement du stop en ville grâce au
partenariat qu'on a avec les entreprises
du plateau de saclay donc via
l'association paul vi dont qui contient
le cea danone thalès polytechnique
l'onera etc
on est en train de lancer courant
décembre
et sur les quatre prochains mois la
première expérimentation de d'auto-stop
intelligent sur un territoire aussi
grand
et là l'objectif c'est de déployer ce
service sur toute l'île de france pour
en 2015 on est quand même très fier
d'avoir ces porteurs de projets qui nous
rappelle que paris saclay innove
autrement que technologiquement